hey guys merry here with a gamespot news
update a new free to play pokemon game
has been announced for ios and android a
trailer for the upcoming game cookie
[ __ ] shows players able to find catch
and battle pokemon by using their
smartphones real-world location the game
will also be playable with the device
called Pokemon go plus it's basically
like a watch it's worn on the wrist and
used to execute in-game actions such as
catching pokemon the device will connect
to smartphones using bluetooth it will
vibrate and flash its LEDs to notify
players about nearby Pokemon details on
how the game plays are still unknown but
the CEO of the pokemon company said he's
been working on Pokemon go with the late
Nintendo CEO Satoru Iwata for around two
years Pokemon go will be released on the
app store and google play in 2016 as a
free download with in-app purchases I
don't know about you but I'm gonna hurry
up and get my Pokemon go + right away
you don't want to be a slowpoke
for everything else pokemon related stay
tuned to Game five